when the coronavirus first arrived in
the united states
few places were hit as hard as nursing
homes and few nursing homes were hit as
hard as the menlo park veterans memorial
home
in central new jersey a wall street
journal investigation found that nearly
100 people died at menlo in april
more than 10 times the number in a
typical month
[Music]
a spokesman for the state agency that
runs menlo declined to respond to most
of the journal's questions
citing expected litigation but in august
reporter chris weaver
interviewed vietnam veteran and
surviving resident glenn osborne
to understand more about what happened
to the residents of menlo park
now that we're nearly six months out
from the beginnings of
the pandemic do you feel like you know
the status of all the residents who you
knew before the outbreak began
i would say 85 i know there's a few i
don't know
and i would like to know of a couple
residents that i knew
socially where they are
recently even though i'm not supposed
to wander out i've gone out and i would
find them
they're so weak they can hardly talk
and they're so pale and they're not
moving and they're still trying to
recover from this disease
it's a horrible thing to see among the
dead
were 84 year old isabella kovacs and 86
year old joan williams
their stories provide a window into what
went wrong at menlo park
[Music]
the menlo park memorial veterans home
accepts veterans their spouses and gold
star parents
it has 312 beds in six residential units
all with patriotic names stars and
stripes where the dementia patients
lived
and freedom where joan lived
joan moved to menlo in 2015 she was
elected to be representative to the
resident council
for about three years running she would
travel
up and down the hallway of freedom
talking to the residents asking what is
their concerns
and that can go on for a half hour at a
time sometimes
we would go to visit her and even
family members of other residents knew
my mother on a first name basis
she always had her makeup together her
hair done and
you know just a classy type of lady
isabella kovacs arrived at menlo park in
january 2020
she had served in both the army and the
air force like joan she was in the
freedom unit
once we got here they had a welcome a
little room
the big sign that said welcome on a
chalkboard and they had a balloon for
her
and they brought us all beverages and
offered us some lunch
but she would have little time to settle
in
not long after isabella arrived there
was an outbreak in the life care nursing
home in kirkland washington
and soon after the coronavirus began
spreading rapidly in nursing homes
around the country
still menlo was caught flat-footed by
the outbreak and the administration's
best attempts to mitigate the spread
fell
short they created a quarantine area for
coveted patients within the alzheimer's
unit
stars and stripes it was separated from
the rest of the unit with a plastic tarp
and the home resisted other more obvious
safety measures
one of the things that we keep hearing
about is that the staff
weren't wearing protective equipment all
the time and in fact that it sounds like
the administration might have instructed
them not to
for some reason yes i actually witnessed
senior administration physically removed
the protective equipment from the
storage cabinet
they were said we don't want you to wear
it because you'll frighten the residents
and that frightened me more than
anything staff members claim they were
not allowed to wear masks
outside the quarantine unit a march 27
email from the new jersey department of
veterans affairs to menlo ceo
outlined the escalating consequences for
mask insubordination
oral counseling written warning
official reprimand and suspension
menlo spokesman declined to comment but
brigadier general mark patierski
who is deputy director of the agency at
the time but has since retired
said masks were in short supply and the
agency
was following federal guidelines
joan and isabella's story takes a turn
in the end of march
i spoke to her on a regular basis i
spoke to the nurse supervisor
she was doing fine she was doing fine
on march 30th menlo resident rose dente
tested positive for the virus
at an emergency room at a nearby
hospital
she died the next day the virus was
inside menlo park but the administration
didn't tell residents families april 3rd
is when i lost communication with my mom
the fourth
still can't get in touch with mom the
fifth
can't get in touch with the nurses
station can't get in touch with mom
joan was somewhere on the freedom unit a
few days after sherry lost track of her
she was put into room 239
alongside isabella kovacs it was obvious
by then joan was very sick
she was asleep all the time and they
were in there checking her temperature
all day long she said
the staff wouldn't tell me anything but
in an april 6
email the home ceo elizabeth schiff
heedles asked for permission to tell
residents and their family members that
kovid was spreading
the next day april 7th she mailed that
letter
but more than a week after the first
resident tested positive for coronavirus
it was too late for joan she was
transferred to room 753
in stars and stripes and later that
night to the hospital
mom tested positive for covid
her lungs were in very bad condition so
it was like a perfect
storm back at menlo isabella was getting
sick
she too was transferred somewhere in
stars and stripes i asked three
different staff members
if they were going to test her for coven
and all three said we don't test for
coping here
on april 12th well into the outbreak of
menlo
the new jersey department of military
and veterans affairs
posted this video on facebook it shows
the staff and ceo of the home
shift heedles dancing in the hallways in
an apparent effort
to raise the resident's spirits menlo
declined to comment
they trying to say they're trying to
cheer us up
i was in shock they were dancing in the
hallways
where literally the residents were dying
in the rooms that they were passing by
the plastic sheet separating stars and
stripes from the rest of the facility
was sagging
staff members in full ppe went back and
forth across the partition
more and more residents were being
shuffled throughout the home
isabella was sent to the emergency room
on april 17th
and also tested positive for covin she
and joan were dying
they let me going up i put on two masks
and a face shield i had two pairs of
gloves
i told her about heaven and i listed the
names of
everybody she's gonna see again
i told her that she was the best mother
i've ever could have had and how much i
loved her
and they're actually gonna get this mask
off and she's gonna
fly free and
i couldn't i couldn't stay in there that
long because i was just
i didn't want her to just hear me cry i
was just crying a lot so
and then the nurse knocked on the door
and i told her i said mom i love you
and that's the less
that i was with my mother
unfortunately both passed away within a
couple of days of one another
i wanted to you know share those details
with you only because it does seem like
you know her particular past kind of
covers some of the same ground that we
were speaking about generally earlier
means a lot to me i appreciate it thank
you
joan williams died on april 21st
isabella kovacs died on april 23rd
their families are among those that have
begun the process of suing the agency
that runs menlo
the agency reported just 62 deaths in
its official tally
a spokesman said that count is based on
expert's conclusions
and that the agency mourns the loss of
every veteran at its facilities
but dozens more died with coveted-like
symptoms according to internal patient
records
many of those residents were never
tested their families say
the new jersey department of health
ultimately confirmed the journal's
findings
revealing another 39 probable coveted
deaths at menlo
i have lost more friends more good
veterans than i did in the war and
combat
these are true heroes that they fought
for america
they were wounded soldiers and came back
came back from world war ii in korea and
vietnam
only to be left here
and treated within dignity and not cared
for not protected
[Music]
you